so i don't have good news to start with
today today we we have to start talking
seriously i mean listen i could lie to
you i could come to you and say 2022 is
looking great for democrats it's looking
great for the left uh but it's not 2022
is looking disastrous and we're going to
look at every data point or most data
points that we have now and then i'm
going to talk about what could change
the direction of 2022 but it it's not
looking good democrats are
if nothing changes and that's a key key
part of it if nothing changes democrats
are heading towards a possibly historic
crushing by republicans in the 2022
midterms now historically when one party
takes the white house in the immediate
first midterm it's not typically great
for that party so because joe biden took
the white house from a republican in
2020 we would expect it's not pointing
to being great
for democrats in 2022 but it's looking
particularly poor now there are some
democrats that are sounding the alarm
and it's angering some on the left even
if they're basically right in what
they're saying elizabeth warren is one
such democrat elizabeth warren now on
multiple shows appearing and saying
democrats are going to lose in 2022 if
we don't deliver more
elizabeth warren delivered a warning on
sunday saying if they don't get up and
deliver while their party has the
majority they will lose
quote there's so much we can do and if
we do it over the next 200 days we're
going to be in fine shape take it to the
people what we've done
um i think we're going to be in real
trouble if we don't get up and deliver
then i believe that democrats are going
to lose now what she's saying kind of
like generically is fine
if we do stuff people like will win and
if we don't then we're going to lose but
she's increasingly using this language
because she sees the writing on the wall
and what is the writing on the wall well
every sign looks bad for democrats and
we can go through some of them first and
foremost how popular is joe biden now
there are some
headlines that say oh my god joe biden
in the low 30s approval
we look at an average of polling and if
you look at an average biden's approval
has ticked up just a hair from like 41
and a half to closer to 43 over the last
month but it's not good and we've looked
at these historical numbers before if
you compare joe biden to past presidents
he's now as unpopular as trump was at
this point in trump's presidency
he's less popular than obama he's less
popular than george w bush he's less
popular than clinton he's less popular
than george h.w bush
slightly less popular than reagan about
as popular as jimmy carter okay so we're
going back really far now to find a
president that at this point in their
first term was this unpopular in a sense
midterms are a referendum on the
president
whether they should be or not and so
that's not particularly good if you look
at a generic ballot do voters want
democrats or republicans in pot in in
congress
right now
republicans have about a two and a half
point advantage
in a generic ballot now the problem is
that because of gerrymandering which
favors republicans big picture at the
national level
this small advantage for republicans
which is growing a little bit by the way
might
significantly favor republicans when it
comes to the house because of
gerrymandering if we look at predict it
predict it is where you can bet on
different elements of politics the
question who will be speaker of the
house next congress which the speaker is
a member of the party that's in control
70 cents of every dollar is going behind
it being kevin mccarthy who will be
speaker of the house and then nine cents
is going to steve scalise both are
republicans meaning 79 cents of every
dollar in fact it's more because jim
jordan's getting five cents and donald
trump is getting four cents and elise
stefanik is getting three cents so 79
84
88
91 cents of every dollar are going to
it's going to be a republican speaker of
the house that's not good now betting
markets aren't polls but that's the
point betting markets are
where do i put my money
when it comes to what i think will
happen not what i want to happen
also unpredicted what will be the
balance of power after 2022
75 cents of every dollar is going to it
will be both a republican house and
senate
um
so these these numbers are not looking
particularly good and then lastly the
politico forecast says the senate is
leaning republican whereas the house is
likely republican so
this is very very very bad now could
everybody be wrong well i think the
question is could things change between
now and when the uh people start voting
which is in just a few months but
something has to happen number one
there's this old phrase it's the economy
stupid and when you and i if we soberly
look at the economy the economy is
actually doing okay yes there's high
inflation but it looks like it's peaking
and it will start to decline gas prices
have been high but they're already
starting to decline unemployment we are
very close to full employment what about
wages that's always a question
but we are very close to full employment
if not there
um the stock market very shaky and it
could be on its way to a downturn but
the stock market is still nearly high
historically high levels most indicators
are pretty good but americans don't know
it we just did a story a couple weeks
ago about a poll where like a third of
americans think there have been job
losses while joe biden has been
president there have been dramatic job
gains under biden now of course you can
always say are they quality jobs and you
can always ask those questions but by
the numbers we typically accept to look
at
there have been massive job gains under
biden and a third of americans think
we've lost jobs so it's not the economy
it's the perception of the economy and
many americans think it's not so good
the one thing i do want to mention
the supreme court
very soon could be weeks at this could
be four weeks could be more like eight
between four and eight weeks from now
the supreme court is going to make a
ruling about a state abortion
ban
and
if they uphold i believe it's the
mississippi law
it will effectively overturn roe v wade
which has been the law of the land
making abortion legal in most cases for
decades in the united states
it would be terrible if the supreme
court did that and i wonder is that a
catalyst that could really motivate
democratic voters to come out and say
we've got to do something about this i
don't want that to happen i want the
supreme court to make the right decision
but if they don't and they effectively
overturn roe v wade
what will that do
in terms of motivating democrats to say
well
i have to go and support
whoever it is at the state level
governor senate
even if i don't think joe biden's been
fantastic because this is so important
women getting the right to decide for
themselves what they need to do
taken away
so that's a question mark i would love
to hear from you
what else could happen between now and
november that would change what are very
grim numbers for democrats let me know
what you think